on this monday night the prime
minister's visit to a bc first nation
justin trudeau's in-person apology for
that tofino vacation say i wish i had
been here a few weeks ago and i deeply
regret it as indigenous leaders tell him
enough with empty words
reconciliation
starts with real action
and residential school survivors speak
their minds our children deserve a good
future and our families deserve peace
america's first black secretary of state
dead at 84. the world lost one of the
greatest leaders that we have ever
witnessed colin powell's complicated
legacy
and airfares are taking off why the cost
of flying is soaring
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
prime minister justin trudeau was told
today indigenous people want more than
empty words and hollow apologies and
that he needs to do hard work to build
trust and make amends
someone must be charged for the deaths
of our children they deserve the dignity
to be named
and either ceremonially or physically
returned to their homelands
trudeau visited the tekemloops to
sequence first nation in bc today a
place he flew over on the first national
day for truth and reconciliation
choosing instead to vacation into fino
that day he since said sorry and today
was told that is a first step but not
nearly enough
today
is about making some positive steps
forward and rectifying
a mistake it was a long awaited moment
to receive a personal hand of
recognition
and sympathy regarding this horrific
confirmation of unmarked graves from the
canadian
head of state
robin gill is in kamloops with our top
story tonight robin
donna the prime minister finally made it
to kamloops and during his visit the
chief of the tekemploops first nation
admonished him and once again he was
forced to apologize
i am here today
to say i wish i had been here a few
weeks ago and i deeply regret it this
was always going to be a day for the
prime minister to appear humbled and to
kemplous to schweppnick chief roseanne
kasamir pulled no punches over justin
trudeau declining two invitations to
visit the bc first nation on this year's
first ever day for truth and
reconciliation the shock
anger
and sorrow and disbelief was palpable in
our community and it rippled throughout
the world to say the least but she was
still willing to sit beside him and make
a commitment toward reconciliation today
is bittersweet
they invited you three weeks ago global
news cameras spotted the prime minister
on a family vacation in tofino he was
contrite when finally accepting this
invitation i had the opportunity this
morning to apologize to her and to the
community in person for not having been
here on september 30th the political
back and forth has overshadowed what
this community has urged the prime
minister to see firsthand for months the
site of suspected graves at the former
kamloops indian residential school
it was envisioned that it would be an
opportunity for him to interact with a
wide array of survivors
intergenerational survivors and many
different first nations in their
meetings the first nation again stressed
the need for full unfettered access to
student attendance records from
residential schools funding for a new
healing center and more help supporting
surveys for other unmarked burial sites
he needs to understand
what we went through rose miller
attended the school from 1949 to 1953 at
80 years of age she can't move on until
these demands are met i think it's only
proper that the government takes some
responsibility to find the other bodies
that are buried here i'm sure there's
going to be more and they need the money
to do it in all the other ones across
canada
it's very important that we have a
closure to it
after the prime minister left indigenous
leaders here say it was simply a photo
op for the prime minister that he
offered no concrete timeline for the
issues presented to him and many
indigenous communities are watching what
happens in kamloops because they too are
dealing with suspected unmarked graves
right across the country donna
robin gill and kamloops vc thanks and
for more on trudeau's visit and what the
federal government is actually doing and
prepared to do let's go to our chief
political correspondent david aiken
david what did the prime minister show
up with during his trip to the kamloops
to
first nation
well he showed up with yet another
symbol donna in this case a commitment
to lower the canadian flags on the next
national day of truth and reconciliation
might be a nice gesture but it was
pretty clear that indigenous leaders at
this point are looking for more than
just symbols more than just another
contrite apology
i think we're beyond
theatrics platitudes and words
and as stated by many indigenous peoples
in this country we need to see action
as you your cabinet comes to be in this
next monday
do something concrete it's really
important
well david clear message there the prime
minister told they want concrete things
that actions speak louder than words
what do we expect in the weeks ahead in
in cabinet and the throne speech
well let's start with the throne speech
another symbol that's going to be read
for the first time by an indigenous
person an inuk woman mary simon our
governor general that's important and
it's a symbol again but people want
concrete actions we heard today about
funding for healing centers funding to
find more of these lost burial sites at
residential schools around the country
and those will have to be somewhere you
would expect in the throne speech one of
the other symbols right now of course is
we've got that water problem up in
iqaluit and that reminds us how the
trudeau government in 2015 six years ago
promised to eliminate all drinking water
advisories we still have 32 communities
tonight who don't have safe drinking
water and so we come back again to
frustration among first nations leaders
all the hopes all the promises of six
years ago and really the trudeau
government not living up uh with their
actions
all right david aiken in ottawa thanks
in manitoba officials are expanding
their rollout of third doses of the
kobit 19 vaccine all first nations
people living on manitoba reserves are
now eligible for a third dose health
officials say the test
positivity rate is significantly higher
on reserves than in the rest of the
province and they're urging all of those
eligible to get a third shot
first nations communities are seeing
breakthrough cases of cobit 19 among
people who are fully vaccinated due to
the context within first nations
communities it's essential that we
decrease transmission as well as
preserve our local health care capacity
the bc government is being urged to
speed up the rollout of booster shots
for seniors third doses are being
administered to residents of assisted
living and long-term care homes but
several facilities are already dealing
with significant outbreaks over the
weekend three new outbreaks were
declared in the greater vancouver area
including this residence in chilliwack
all three facilities have introduced
enhanced measures to help control the
spread of infections and have closed
their doors to new admissions nearly
three-quarters of the residents of
another long-term care home in burnaby
have now tested positive for the virus
three people there have died and health
officials say the number could be as
high as 10.
saskatchewan's health authority has
begun transferring critically ill
patients to ontario for intensive care
to help ease the strain on
saskatchewan's hospitals
our numbers are reducing our
hospitalizations have reduced the last
10 days but our intensive care numbers
continue to be high and that's what's
precipitating today's decision
one patient is being transferred today
and up to six transfers are expected by
the end of wednesday with longer term
plans being assessed the number of
patients requiring intensive care in
saskatchewan is far exceeding the number
of available beds some icus are
operating at up to 153 percent capacity
premier scott moe has requested federal
help to staff the icus and relieve some
of the pressure on front line health
care workers
u.s president joe biden has paid tribute
to colin powell saying even in
disagreement powell was always someone
who gave you his best and treated you
with respect powell a retired four-star
general and former u.s secretary of
state has died of complications of
covid19 at the age of 84. his family
says powell was fully vaccinated but had
multiple myeloma a cancer of plasma
cells that suppresses the body's immune
system as well as parkinson's both
conditions made him vulnerable to the
virus powell played a pivotal role
especially in the aftermath of 9 11. and
as jackson proskow reports his legacy is
complex he was a soldier a diplomat and
a man who broke barriers to many colin
powell exemplified the american dream
growing up in harlem the son of jamaican
immigrants he went on to advise four
different presidents
powell joined the army and served his
country during two tours of vietnam
becoming a general
ronald reagan tapped him as national
security adviser in the final days of
the cold war
president george h.w bush made him
chairman of the joint chiefs the first
black person to hold the post
he oversaw the persian gulf war in 1991
his strategy of overwhelming force
became known as the powell doctrine our
strategy to go after this army is very
very simple first we're going to cut it
off and then we're going to kill it his
presence and earnest demeanor made him
one of the most popular and trusted
names in america by the time he retired
from the military
he was arguably the most respected and
celebrated american in uniform
republicans and democrats tried to
convince him to run for president his
wife alma talked him out of it colin l
powell
as secretary of state it was under
president george w bush that powell was
appointed secretary of state another
first for an african-american
despite his reservations about invading
iraq he relented sodom hussein and his
regime are concealing their efforts to
produce more weapons of mass destruction
that speech to the united nations
arguably won the battle for public
opinion and would become one of his
greatest regrets as iraq turned into a
quagmire powell admitted to relying on
faulty intelligence acknowledging the
painful stain on his record
in his later years powell positioned
himself as a moderate endorsing barack
obama and serving as an informal advisor
in 2020 he endorsed a democrat again joe
biden will be a president we will all be
proud to salute are you optimistic
powell's career paved the way for a
generation of future leaders including
the current u.s secretary of defense the
world lost one of the greatest leaders
that we have ever witnessed
in his later years as american politics
grew more divided powell kept a
noticeably lower profile avoiding the
spotlight and the sting of his iraq
blunder
asked how he might like to be remembered
he once told an interviewer all i want
to do is judge myself as a successful
soldier who served his best
colin powell was 84.
jackson proskow global news washington
there is a development in the case of
sexual misconduct allegations against
one of the top men in the canadian armed
forces a day after his accuser spoke
exclusively with global news military
officials say the decision not to
prosecute admiral art mcdonald does not
mean the claims against him are
unfounded mcdonald has claimed he's been
exonerated and he's fighting to be
reinstated as chief of the defense staff
a post he held for just one month before
accusations against him emerged as
abigail beeman explains the whole thing
has left the military in leadership
limbo
there were several witnesses several
witnesses says navy lieutenant heather
mcdonald who saw her alleged sexual
assault one of them tells global news
she's telling the truth and he told that
to military police but military police
said the investigation did not produce
evidence to lay charges against admiral
art mcdonald who recently asked for his
job back in a letter to top military
officials claiming his exoneration i
take big issue with it
because that's simply not a fact
there was no exoneration of any sort
maybe it was expected by him
and it's a it's a most generous
interpretation of the decision not to
prosecute or not to pursue these
allegations it's a misperception and i
think just sort of a signal
that he simply wants his power back that
bold kind of move is just such a
you know again a testimony to how out of
touch he is late monday military police
issued a statement saying they wanted to
clarify no charges laid does not mean
that the allegation was unfounded there
are now calls for an independent review
of mcdonald's case but of course the
push to handle sexual misconduct cases
outside the military is not new i would
ask that parliament
start taking some of some of the
recommendations they have been given for
action this is unprecedented it's a
leadership crisis that
i know of no
no other large nation i know g7 g20
nation some believe the prime minister
will wait to name a new cabinet before
sorting out the cds role and top of the
cabinet speculation list is whether
defense minister harjit sajan keeps his
job i do not have faith
that a prime minister that has kept his
mouth shut on this issue for most of the
year while the military has been in
crisis
i don't think he's going to
be the right person to make to pick a
minister who's going to lead on this
because he himself hasn't led on this
global news put a number of questions to
the defense minister and prime
minister's office in the wake of
lieutenant heather mcdonald's interview
we asked sajin if he'll be calling for a
review of the case sidestepping the
question his office told us anyone is
free to make a complaint to the military
police complaints commission of canada
the prime minister's office wouldn't
answer by deadline on the question of a
review or when justin trudeau expects to
make a decision about who becomes the
permanent chief of the defense staff
abigail bieben global news ottawa
the abduction of 17 missionaries in
haiti including a canadian coming up the
gang being blamed for the kidnappings
[Music]
governor general mary mae simon is on
her first international trip
representing canada simon was greeted in
berlin by german chancellor angela
merkel she'll take part in several
events including roundtable talks about
arctic exploration and a trip to the
frankfurt book fair the world's largest
trade show for literary works
a powerful haitian gang is believed to
be behind the kidnappings of 17
missionaries over the weekend including
one canadian there's no functioning
government
and the gang's rule port-au-prince in
the country at large
the missionaries work for christian aid
ministries it says they were abducted
after visiting an orphanage and among
those being held are five children
kidnappings have become more frequent in
haiti since the assassination of the
country's president this summer the fbi
says it's now assisting in efforts to
locate and free the hostages
ahead the soaring cost of flights as air
travel recovers from the pandemic
as travel rules ease more canadians are
taking to the skies but those booking
flights are encountering a troubling
trend airfare prices are reaching new
highs ross lord explains what's behind
this surge in fairs
for carol wamba flying from ottawa to
africa is emotional it's very tough i
lost my mom so i'm going because i lost
my mom at two thousand dollars a ticket
she says her airfare is almost double
what it was before the pandemic she'll
be flying alone i'm really sad because
my son would have loved traveling with
me he's especially child
and i always travel with it but this
time i couldn't do that because of i
didn't have enough
money
flying from one part of canada to
another has also become more expensive
the aviation data supplier cerium says
between july of 2019 and july of 2021
the average price of a round-trip ticket
within canada went up by almost 100
to 532 dollars plus taxes
wire fares even higher than before the
pandemic
cerium says there's pet up demand but
only half as many seats available
because canadian airlines are still
offering fewer flights and using smaller
planes when the system senses that seats
are selling out fast it automatically
raises the price because it says well
there's very few seats left we don't
want to give them away we want to charge
more for them so that those who really
need to travel can actually get a seat
and so a lot of it is actually
algorithms
cold calculations and cold comfort for
travelers looking forward to moving more
freely unpredictable
depends on what day you choose to fly
but i've noticed that the flights within
canada are super crazy high
the airlines themselves are breathing
easier now that the devastating impacts
of covert 19 are beginning to ease
travel restrictions have rolled off
confidence has been returning
i think the government's vaccination
mandates do provide more confidence
people to get travelling again so things
are certainly moving in the right
direction when things will move in the
right direction for consumers is unclear
analysts say prices could keep climbing
possibly through the christmas holidays
until airlines switch back to larger
planes and more available seats
ross lord global news
residential school survivors and their
families speak out next what they told
the prime minister
returning now to our top story the visit
by prime minister justin trudeau to the
chem loops to
first nation in bc most places he goes
he commands the attention of the room
he's the one everyone looks to and
listens to
today it was his turn to listen here is
some of what kamloops residential school
survivors and their families had to say
when i left that school up there i
didn't know how to love myself i didn't
know how to love my children
my five children
taught me how to love them
and i pray
that we can have it in our hearts
to start forgiving
and start working and making
that truth and reconciliation
a path
for all of us
for the children of the future
for the children of the past
for the children of now the present
since the age of five i feel like i have
been in survivor mode and i'm 53 years
old now it has been a long road
we hear about the loss of culture and
the loss of our language but as children
growing up in the wake of the
residential school era we lost so much
more
we lost our parents
our moms our dads grew up in an
institution
a regulated cold institution that forced
through violence not to have feelings
our parents are not able to freely show
love or emotions
we rarely experience our family members
dying of natural causes old age
our deaths are from addictions overdoses
violence suicides chronic health
conditions and poverty
the anger and the frustration
is hard to
hard to swallow my mom went to this
institution
and i would say to my mom
hey mom you know may 27th
of this year 2021
the children
the children
uttered these words
to the world
you found us
you found us
we are here because
every man woman and child mother and
father grand grandmother grandfather
aunt and uncle you're warriored up you
survived over a hundred years of this
institution
we're still here
we're still here
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is this view of the sunrise on
mount baker in washington state seen
from mission bc
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]